sometimes even to live is an act of
courage
we suffer more in imagination than in
reality
as long as you live keep learning how to
live
[Music]
the bravest site in the world is to see
a great man struggling against adversity
all cruelty springs from weakness
luck is what happens when preparation
meets opportunity
religion is regarded by the common
people as true by the wise as false and
by rulers as useful
[Music]
wherever there is a human being there is
an opportunity for a kindness
[Music]
it is not because things are difficult
that we do not dare it is because we do
not dare that things are difficult
[Music]
difficulties strengthen the mind as
labor does the body
begin at once to live and count each
separate day as a separate life
[Music]
throw me to the wolves and i will return
leading the pack
ignorance is the cause of fear
if one does not know to which port one
is sailing no wind is favorable
[Music]
we become wiser by adversity prosperity
destroys our appreciation of the right
[Music]
as is a tale so is life not how long it
is but how good it is is what matters
nothing is more honorable than a
grateful heart
[Music]
the good things of prosperity are to be
wished but the good things that belong
to adversity are to be admired
silence is a lesson learned through
life's many sufferings
you act like mortals in all that you
fear and like immortals and all that you
desire
they lose the day and expectation of the
night and the night in fear of the dawn
he suffers more than necessary who
suffers before it is necessary
[Music]
one of the most beautiful qualities of
true friendship is to understand and to
be understood
[Music]
how does it help to make troubles
heavier by bemoaning them
[Music]
hang on to your youthful enthusiasms
you'll be able to use them better when
you're older
[Music]
associate with people who are likely to
improve you
[Music]
true happiness is to enjoy the present
without anxious dependence upon the
future
[Music]
wealth is the slave of the wise the
master of the fool
it does not matter what you bear but how
you bear it
[Music]
it is the power of the mind to be
unconquerable
[Music]
we learn not in the school but in life
[Music]
a gift consists not in what is done or
given but in the intention of the giver
or doer
[Music]
it is not the man who has too little but
the man who craves more who is poor
the whole future lies in uncertainty
live immediately
[Music]
we are always complaining that our days
are few and acting as though there would
be no end of them
there is no genius without a touch of
madness
anger if not restrained is frequently
more hurtful to us than the injury that
provokes it
[Music]
he is most powerful who has power over
himself
[Music]
the man who has anticipated the coming
of troubles takes away their power when
they arrive
[Music]
what need is there to weep over parts of
life
the whole of it calls for tears
[Music]
life if well lived is long enough
[Music]
for many men the acquisition of wealth
does not end their troubles it only
changes them
[Music]
no man was ever wise by chance
i shall never be ashamed of citing a bad
author if the line is good
[Music]
to bear trials with a calm mind rob's
misfortune of its strength and burden
[Music]
life is like a play it's not the length
but the excellence of the acting that
matters
[Music]
things that were hard to bear are sweet
to remember
[Music]
i am not born for one corner the whole
world is my native land
if thou art a man admire those who
attempt great things even though they
fail
we should always allow some time to
elapse for time discloses the truth
[Music]
a gem cannot be polished without
friction nor a man perfected without
trials
[Music]
regard a friend as loyal and you will
make him loyal
[Music]
it is quality rather than quantity that
matters
[Music]
he who indulges in empty fears earns
himself real fears
[Music]
enjoy present pleasures in such a way as
not to injure future ones
[Music]
let us train our minds to desire what
the situation demands
[Music]
smart men don't marry stupid women
[Music]
while we are postponing live speeds by
[Music]
everything that exceeds the bounds of
moderation has an unstable foundation
[Music]
it is better to conquer our grief than
to deceive it
[Music]
whatever can happen at any time can
happen today
[Music]
a man's as miserable as he thinks he is
[Music]
of this one thing make sure against your
dying day that your faults die before
you do